[Musique]
je me souviens des histoires qui courait
propos des censeurs est ce vrai ce qu'on
raconte les ailes sont les premiers
magicien de ce continent
lorsque les humains et les monstres sont
arrivés les elfes ont appris aux humains
a transformé le chaos en magie et
ensuite les humains les ont massacrés
2 k o est la chose la plus dangereuse en
ce monde
sans contrôle
aux futurs as
pour toi voilà à quoi la vie se résume
des monstres hideux l'argent n'a rien
d'autre à ma portée quelque chose tu
attends
cet enfant sera extraordinaire
bien ever imagine la plus puissante des
femmes en ce monde
es tu à la hauteur
cardenas
c'est pourrais-je qui semble
tu ne peux pas fuir la destinée sous
prétexte qu'elle te terrifie
sa coupure a trouvé deux rives
je n'y arriverai pas sans toi
peu importe ce que tu choisis
tu en sortiras maculé de sang
ils pouvaient m'en voyez n'importe quel
joueur
pourquoi elle a choisi toi tu me neeman
henry c'était déjà arrivé avant quoi
donc que ton gouvernement cherche à
l'éliminer
non ça c'est nouveau tout ce que nous
avons créées est en danger vous n'avez
personne capable de tuer henry brogan
gemini va s'en charger
et qui je crois est cool moi je peux
alors j'ai la recrue idéale
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il connaissait le moindre de mes
mouvements à l'avant ce qui sait
je sais pourquoi il est aussi fort que
toi gemini se prend pour dieu en jouant
avec l'adn
comment c'est possible quitte à cloner
quelqu'un aurait pu clown et nelson
mandela
sa demande est là réussir est pas à tuer
un homme à deux kilomètres d'un cintre
en marche
il pouvait envoyer n'importe quel joueur
pourquoi es tu as choisi thouars parce
que je suis le meilleur tu est
clairement pas le meilleur notre pose
pas de questions il doit mourir
regarde bien il te ment depuis le début
j'essaie de me déstabiliser non j'essaie
de sauver
imaginez que quelqu'un découvre
ce qu'on est vraiment toi et moi
[Musique]
rentrez chez vous on veut pas de vous
ici maman pourquoi il nous persécutent
[Musique]
les gens comme toi
alban une mène une existence qui est
pavé de souffrance et de douleur
vous dites ça à cause de mer
votre façon de vivre à l'écart des
autres et devrait vous brûlez vous nous
prenez part des sorcières
votre existence où est ton mari
attirer certains fidèles vers les
ténèbres
on n'a pas besoin d'avoir peur
pour le bien de la communauté
à
nous devons purifier
je
les femmes comme vous alors
qu'attendez-vous
à cette époque je ne savais pas ce qu'il
pouvait nous faire ni à quel point cette
guerre
allez me changer
et elle s'équipe de forces spéciales
c'est aussi une révolution féministe non
notre révolution ne connaît aucune
frontière
durant des milliers d'années les sommes
en guerre sont passés sur le corps des
femmes
[Applaudissements]
et ici pour la première fois nous
craignent
puis tu laisses moi tu parles on ya pas
de remercier j'ai décidé de rejoindre
mes soeurs d'armes pour venger mon père
est sauvé mon frère
[Musique]
c'est quoi ton nom zalla moi cela ouvre
et celle qui conduit si american snipers
s'achète
on l'appelle la lionne de cobalt
à jouer
[Applaudissements]
baird
une fois qu'on a plus besoin d'elle les
femmes sont est passé de l'histoire
effacée de la société
est renvoyée chez elle
pour être des esclaves
mais pas cette fois
chez moi
georgine demain c'est fini les mariages
là on passe au stade supérieur nafi
allez papa dada mais je ne peux pas ta
compagne et demain mais j'y vais pas
sans toi papa derniers jours j'aimerais
bien que tu accompagnes dans la classe
heures de ma journée vous coucher
évidemment ce nom il invite dans la même
ville c'était pour moi un nom qu'on
s'est pas vu quand on déjeune une heure
toutes les deux on n'a rien à se dire et
là tu nous demande de faire quatre
heures de route ensemble
c'est le dernier tour des auditions pour
les choristes francophone de céline on
ne dit pas que tu dit céline pour ces
lignes on ne veut pas dire pascal
s'appelle céline
moi j'ai ma fille
ça fait plaisir mais caissière
m c'était impulsion août est fatigué on
a quatre heures de route on va pas se
parler pendant quatre heures 6
c'est bizarre de vouloir être choriste
vouloir être derrière quelqu'un qui fait
le même métier qu à cacher dans le noir
je trouve ça hyper étrange en béton au
moins un rythme une à dire je te dérange
te poses des questions tu me réponds que
par oui ou par non
c'était quelques heures faire un attrait
plateau ça ça pour être les paroles
d'une chanson tu évolues vous vivez dans
quel monde fera pas une fois encore pas
par quoi papa c'est quoi le problème est
quand même c'est que je parle comme vous
moi moi je veux pas mentir je pense à
vouloir vous protéger des malades les
malades combat et nous faisait rencontré
dans le quartier ça a été le coup de
foudre
depuis huit jours je m'attache à jour
pas marqué bon ça suffit j'appelle mon
mari est sûre cet imbécile de côté
voulez-vous mari un imbécile
les maris des femmes qui nous plaît ce
sont toujours des abbés ces exactions
montagnole quelle bonne surprise c'est
pas que chez moi oui le franchement
faisant des mains non plus si jeune
femme respectable il vous drague
pourquoi vous croyez avoir l'exclusivité
un homme que vous connaissez depuis dix
minutes 20 chez la femme dansant s'étant
bien j'en arrive à ma femme oui
bonjour jours à berlin am oui pas sa
mère
mais là bas ils la violent avait le
mérite
oui tu trouves tu as faim je sais pas si
simple
moi qui croyais fidèles mais comme les
autres
si je surprends mon mari je suis avant
quoi c'est fou j'ai une force au
conditionnel ou hossein
hop jury quand vous n'êtes pas fan
tacticien aux jeunes auteurs
victoire souffert dis moi moi victoire
c'est bien toi non à ces jacky mais je
te demande pas de répondre j'ai jamais
vu ça
mais toi tout ce que je sais je sais que
tu sais que je sais nous savons que nous
savons que nous savons alors ça va j'ai
pas l'air d'un imbécile c'est évident tu
te souviens de cette série docu sur la
spiritualité à travers le monde
il faudra des ambiances musicales
va te faire du bien ce voyage hilti que
tu es triste tu as tu avoir un gros
problème dans ta vie avant d'arriver ici
et je mène peut communiquer avec les
morts oui notre insu autre monde mais
parce que j'étais pouvoir des pouvoirs
magiques tutour maintenant apprendre à
t'en servir si c'est parce que vous me
racontez fait flipper ces bonnes femmes
je perds mon mari c'est déjà assez dur
comme ça on n'a pas le choix c'est ton
destin
je crois pas que tu te réclames aller
consulter voir un médecin
si à chaque fois que vous entendez du
tambour vous prenez pour un loup il ya
quand même un petit problème vous croyez
pas
st paul qui m'appelait peut-être qu'ils
ont raison les schémas noter que j'ai
accès un autre monde pourquoi pas
au lit pour faire avancer la science ça
dérange qui moi ça me dérange t pouvoir
grands
mieux en train de devenir cool les
contes arts et tu te rends même pas
compte
je sais juste d'aller mieux louise
puisque cher merde
quand mayer votre grand mère
[Musique]
juste avant de mourir à ces jurés qu'on
se reverrait
[Musique]
tous